the term flop is used pretty broadly at
this point because a few years back you
probably wouldn't have looked at a movie
that had Rotten Tomato scores of 63% for
critics and 83% for fans and assume it
did well and you look at the fact that
it made 68 million bucks more than it
cost to make and say hey nice job but to
the studios that's a big flop cuz it's
all about projected numbers people and
they were definitely projecting a lot
more for the flash plus the ongoing
legal and mental health issues of its
star Ezra Miller might have been a
factor as well Transformers rise of the
beasts is another one that might seem on
the surface like it did pretty well
after all it grossed $427 million at the
box office around the world and cost
under $200 million to make but by
Transformers standards that was pretty
bad what's interesting is that it
actually had better reviews than most of
its predecessors it's possible people
are just kind of over the franchise